on September 20th euro boss became the
seventh country to cut off diplomatic
relations with Taiwan says the president
sized election four days prior the
Solomon Islands did the same these
decisions to normalize relations with
Beijing by Taiwan's largest Pacific
partners may convince Taipei's three
remaining Pacific allies to reconsider
their physicians poaching Taiwan's
allies helps China isolate the island
which could aid in its so-called
reunification efforts China leverages
trade and promises future investment to
convince countries to switch their
recognition China was a Solomon Islands
biggest trade partner and allegedly
promised them five hundred million
dollars in financial aid China also
promised gearbox full funding for its
airplanes and commercial ferries Taiwan
is at risk of losing more of their
partners because they just can't compete
with Chinese aid in trade
moreover the United States is reducing
aid to some of Taiwan's remaining allies
Congress in the White House are
considering a strategy that would punish
countries for abandoning Taiwan but it
would be more effective to offer
benefits to those that decided to
support Taipei
do you think the United States should
help Taiwan keep its allies let us know
in our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI